president emmanuel macron has presented
his agenda for france's stint at the
helm of the european union he wants to
boost the bloc's role on the world stage
but how much can he achieve and what
obstacles does he face dw's brussels
correspondent christine mundo reports
i've arrived in paris today
because france has taken over the
presidency of the european union and for
the next six months the agenda for
europe if you want to call it that will
be set here in paris
what's clear is that the french
president emmanuel macron has big
ambitions for europe he wants europe in
his own words to be more powerful in the
world
in the heart of paris the country's most
recognizable monument now wears a circle
of stars to mark the eu presidency
france last held 13 years ago
the position gives the french more
influence over the future of the
european union
a more capable europe with its own army
is paris's topmost ambition it's
referred to as strategic autonomy
what that means is a more sovereign more
independent europe particularly when it
comes to the issue of defence do you
feel that europe needs to be more
stronger
well
i'm not sure that that's a good idea but
i i even i i think that we um we depend
too much on the united states now
we would be taken more seriously by
other countries if we had a european
army before we have an army let's have a
union
france's agenda for the union also
includes relaxing rules to allow eu
countries to borrow more money to
finance big infrastructure projects
and
trying to bring the block to consensus
on the long-standing thorny issue of
migration
in december emmanuel macron summed up
the goal of france's eu presidency this
way
we need to move from being a europe of
cooperation inside our borders to a
powerful europe in the world
fully sovereign
free to make its choices and master of
its destiny
but macron's own destiny is in question
france is holding a presidential
election in april if he doesn't get
re-elected he can't see his plans for
europe through
and let's bring in now jacob ross of the
german council on foreign relations in
berlin um jacob tell us macron has never
really made any secret of his ambitions
to be the motor of further european
integration um to what extent does the
eu presidency now give him the platform
to fulfill that goal
thank you well first of all as we have
seen uh with uh mr macron's uh press
conference in in december he's had a a
series of summits for the upcoming or
for the current uh
french council presidency uh including a
summit on
the european union african union or
europe africa relations in february a
summit on european defense in march and
summit another summit on the future of
the european economic model
in march as well
so
as you said earlier the french and the
french government mr macro
have the ability
have the tools now to set the agenda to
to bring their priorities to the
european stage and discuss them with
other member states
and beyond i mean discussing when we
talk about actual results coming out of
those summits talk with us about the
prospects for further european
integration france and germany of course
two of the most powerful nations in the
eu we know germany has a new government
how are things between paris and berlin
right now in pushing that agenda forward
well things looked very good at the end
of last year i mean it's only been a
couple of days in the new year but so
far i think paris is uh
having a positive uh um
seeing positive signals coming from
berlin uh we we saw that with uh
chancellor schultz visiting the elysee
uh in december uh the the new foreign
minister miss berbach the green foreign
minister from germany
visiting her counterpart in paris in
december as well and so i think the
french are
very optimistic for the franco-german
relations and for the impact of these
relations for the
the the european um
cooperation in the coming weeks and
months
uh just to to give a few examples i
think
as i mentioned there will be the summit
in march on european defense
there will probably be news on the
strategic compass the big project on
european defense and security
french president macron and
mr schultz but also the other heads of
states and government from the european
member state will try to to find a
compromise and to bring
uh into reality what mr mccoy indeed
called
passing from uh
are giving europe uh a bigger stance in
international affairs
how about uh support domestically from
macron's agenda we know that he is
facing
domestic uh elections for example and he
set the the the bar at the eu level very
high
and saying i'm quote quoting here 2022
must be the year
of a european turning point
does he have the public support
i think he has the public support but as
we have seen
recently at the turn of the year uh this
public support is uh
could be prone
to to attacks and can shift um the
french put up or the french government i
should say put up a european flag
under the arc de triomphe a very
symbolic place uh on top of the tomb of
the unknown soldier in the center of
paris
and immediately you saw attacks on the
domestic scene from political opponents
predominantly from the political riot
the extreme right but also miss pikrez
from the moderate riot le repudica
so
i think macron mr macron knows that he
has a clear majority of french voters
who are pro-european and who want to see
progress
in european projects but
these these ideas or this majority will
constantly be under attack until the
elections in early april
jacob ross from the german council on
foreign relations thank you so much
thank you
well for more on that let's bring in
hartim shahada a researcher at the
german council on foreign relations here
in berlin uh macron has never made any
secret of his ambition to be the motor
for further european integration does
the eu presidency give him a welcome
platform to put his european record to
the forefront
well to be honest i think macau is now
the chance to really prove that he's
very pro-european that his ambitions
that he's already mentioned in 2017 um
at selburn university are am not very
far away from reality so now he has the
chance to really prove to germany as its
closest ally in europe and also to other
member states that he can really succeed
in what he has planned for for europe
well you mentioned germany that france
and germany are of course the two most
powerful nations in the eu and nothing
moves in the eu without at least one of
the two supporting it uh how are things
right now between paris and berlin
well i think with the new german
government there are some definitely
some um constraints now to the
relationship of france and germany so
with the discussion about eu taxonomy
there is
kind of a
yeah misunderstanding in between those
two countries so france on the one side
wants to push forward its nuclear agenda
whereas germany wants to um push forward
renewable energies so this is one of the
main points of discussion that we
observe at this point
is that a big dispute how much will it
strain relations
well i think right now is the time to
discuss things so macron is now the
chance to approach the other member
states especially germany and he now has
the chance to
convince other member states of his of
his ideas and um i'm not very sure if
germany is going to really accept his
ideas when it comes to nuclear energy so
germany will definitely oppose it
but
it is the chance to really find a
solution and a compromise and this is i
think
the the most basic idea of the rotating
eu presidency to find compromise and um
to gather the member states at one table
and to really discuss things
so macron has set the bar very high
saying 2022 must be the year of a
european turning point
how big is this support for this by the
french public you think
well
as i already mentioned macron has
put forward his ideas already in 2017
during his presidential um election
campaign
and it was perceived as very very
progressive by a lot of french citizens
so the french public has shown itself to
be very pro-european during this
campaign and the following years and i
would even go one step further and say
that the french do like the idea of
having considerable influence on an eu
level to of course push forward
certain political issues um that they
have interest in and even those who are
not very likely to support macron's
ideas of what they you should look like
in future want france to shine during
the next six months
even though they want they may not want
to change europe in
in a machinist way so i would say that
the majority of france will support the
idea of changing europe in either one
way or another
our team charter there from the german
council on foreign relations thank you
very much for your analysis
thank you